I have an extremely strange video to
show you from 2012 I don't know what to
make of it okay and I'm coming to you
not to tell you what we're about to see
in this video but to ask you what you
think is happening in this video I got
an email from a viewer with a link to a
video that makes it look as though in
2012 on a stage with Mitt Romney and his
wife Ann Romney Donald Trump may have
grabbed the rear end of an Romney okay
I'm going to show you the video and the
letter from Adam but to be super crystal
clear I bring this up because and only
because it would be completely in line
with Donald Trump's character and to
what he admits to doing to women and
with the dozen plus other allegations of
similar behavior okay let's start with
the letter I got Adam wrote to me saying
David this is from 2012 when Romney got
Trump's endorsement pay attention to
what happens between Trump and Romney at
the one minute and 53 second point in
the video it looks like Trump grabbed
ends behind what do you think so I
looked at the video and I went in with a
very skeptical eye and something does
seem off about the video and I think
that there's really only two
possibilities here let's take a look at
the video and what you will notice as we
look at it our audience that's watching
will notice that in the video we see at
a certain point Donald Trump's but sort
of moves and Ann Romney kind of like
tenses up and it does seem as though
that is exactly what would happen if
Donald Trump were to have squeezed her
buttocks let's look at it again and
let's even run it just on repeat so
people can get a sense for what's going
on here you will notice that Donald
Trump at a certain point moves and he
has a really weird smirk on his face and
Ann Romney clenches she just moves and
it's almost like she's pushing Trump's
hand away potentially so what do I think
happens I think that there are two
possibilities really the people
possibility one is that the stage shook
and that's why we see both Ann Romney
and Trump sort of adjust at the exact
same time the other possibility is Trump
did grab an Romney's Baja
because it is very very odd it's really
weird and the biggest reason the only
thing that makes me skeptical about this
is that Mitt Romney has not been a
friend of Donald Trump and he has
slammed Donald Trump when Trump has
deserved it I would assume that if an
and MIT Romney had this story to tell
they would have gone public with it if
this is indeed something that Donald
Trump did that's that's the one thing
Pat that I think is out of character
which is Romney would have told us if
Donald Trump had done this to him yeah
Romney probably wouldn't have done it at
the time right I mean just in the midst
of his own presidential election someone
endorsing him or whatever but ever since
Trump snubbed him to become Secretary of
State and they had that dinner you'd
think that mitt and Nan would come out
with this so that's exactly my thought
and and that's why I present it to you
and if you have an explanation let me
know what you think it is take a look at
the video again if you're listening you
can go to our YouTube channel you can
see the video youtube.com slash the
david pakman show and send me your
thoughts and I'm sure that this will be
discussed on our reddit discussion forum
david pakman.com slash our IDI di t
today's episode of the david pakman show
is made possible in part by Warby Parker
eyeglasses Warby Parker recently did the
right thing and ditched advertising on
right-wing conspiracy website Breitbart
pulling their ads off and you can get
the free five-day home Tryon from Warby
Parker check out their glasses I use
them when I'm not wearing contact lenses
I started with the free at-home trial
they send you five pairs of glasses you
see which ones you like you send them
back and whichever one you pick they
will put your prescription in - I like
this because I can actually show the
glasses to other people and not have to
just decide on the spot like in an
eyeglass store the eyeglass industry is
controlled by very few corporations that
keep the prices very very high even over
$300 for prescription glasses with Warby
Parker they start at just 95 bucks mine
costs that including lenses and for
every pair sold they give a pair to
someone in need so to try the five pairs
and support the David Pakman show go to
Warby Parker try
komm /t DPS